piensa en este problema de la vida real
para estimar la población de un pueblo
en los años siguientes
un empleado de gobierno recolector las
cifras de población en años pasados y
las organizó en la siguiente tabla
aquí me dan la tabla tengo los años van
aumentando el 10 en 10 y de este lado
tengo la población en cada uno de esos
años los habitantes del pueblo desean
estimar la población para los años 2015
2018 y 2020 para hacer esto usaría
razonamiento inductivo por razonamiento
deductivo bueno antes de contestar esta
pregunta vamos a pensar un poco en qué
significa cada uno de los dos tipos de
razonamiento razonamiento inductivo es
cuando tomas una colección de datos como
los años y sus poblaciones y tratas de
encontrar un patrón o una tendencia en
la información y ya que tienes esa
tendencia lo que quieres hacer es
generalizar la extrapolar esos datos así
que en el razonamiento inductivo partes
de una tendencia en los datos de una
tendencia
y lo que haces es hacer una
generalización
pero en el razonamiento deductivo tomas
un conjunto de datos que tú sabes que
son ciertos y haces una predicción pero
es una predicción que se tiene que
cumplir es una predicción completamente
certera así que en realidad lo que está
haciendo es tomando hechos cosas que tú
sabes que son verdad hechos
y concluyendo reduciendo otros hechos
cosas que también sabes que son verdad
ahora en este caso me dicen que los
habitantes del pueblo desean estimar la
población para los años 2015 2018 y 2020
estos años están en el futuro así que no
puedo saber con toda seguridad cuál va a
ser la población en esos años lo mejor
que puedo hacer es buscar un patrón en
los datos y obtener una tendencia y
generalizar la y esperar que esa
tendencia se mantenga esa es la
diferencia principal entre el
razonamiento inductivo y el deductivo en
el razonamiento deductivo lo que
concluyo debe ser verdad en el
razonamiento inductivo simplemente puedo
hacer una predicción pero no sé si sea
verdad o no así que en este caso lo que
voy a usar es razonamiento inductivo